a Hong Kong based Shipping Company
suspended its activity to and from
Israel that's after vessels in the Red
Sea came under attack from HTI fisers in
Yemen the houthi say they're going to
continue their attacks if Israel doesn't
stop its war on Gaza their activities
are starting to have far-reaching
consequences not just for Israel but
globally salak reports from the Israeli
Port City of
hia siron sound across the city of
ashdod as iron doome successfully
intercepts Hamas missiles weak after the
war on Gaza started ashdod is one of
Israel's main ports and also the one
closest to the strip it's vulnerable to
attacks and has been forced to divert
some of its
shipments the bulk of them have been
sent to hia one of the safest port
cities in Israel so far 30 million tons
of cargo including oil raw materials and
grain already passed through it annually
but this has come at a cost backlogs and
re-rooting of cargo have created big
delays and raised insurance
premiums Israel is being attacked on
multiple fronts not just from the Gaza
Strip by Hamas but also from further
along the coast on the border with
Lebanon by the Iranian backed group
Hezbollah but even more concerning by
the Hui Rebels firing longrange missiles
and drones towards the port city of
illot the Iranian back group controls
much of Northern Yemen for weeks they've
t targeted ships in the Red Sea they
believe have links with Israel or are
headed to Israeli ports and because the
Red Sea is one of the world's most
important shipping routes the effect has
been
huge it's caused an 80% drop in shipping
activity at elat Insurance prices on
cargo heading to Israel have risen by
300% and with around 12% of global trade
passing through the Red Sea it has
Regional and Global
implications experts say costs of shi
shipping goods are already rising and
several major shipping companies have
pulled their ships from the Red Sea all
together raising costs and lengthening
delivery times it's no longer uh a
threat against Israel it's again it's an
international problem because they are
hitting um boats and ships which have
nothing to do with Israel and there is
another point the Israeli Navy is too
small to deal aone with the
threat the US says it's working with
Maritime forces to bolster Security in
the region a reminder that Israel's war
on Gaza is making its impact felt far
beyond the Middle East s alzer
haa Victoria Mitchell is a maritime
analyst from control risks it's a global
specialist risk consultancy she's
joining us live from Amsterdam thanks
very much indeed for being with us um
just give us an indication of how
important this rot is for
shipping yeah absolutely so thank you
for the invitation and the red seat it
is a critical Maritime route together
with the bab as you've mentioned in your
piece there uh 12% of global trade
passes through the Red Sea and that is a
cross vessel type so we're talking about
containerized uh cargo General cargo
grain uh oil oil products what you've
what what comes into the shops what goes
into the tank all of that will pass
through the Red Sea I know that in in
specific regions such as this one around
the world that piracy has always been
been an issue and I know that some uh
ships usually carry some sort of
protection on on normal circumstances
what kind of protection wood ships be
having that will vary uh depending on
the vessel type and the decision of any
operator who will be transiting these
Waters but uh vessels may elect to adopt
hardening measures consistent with
advisory advisories for the waters uh
some vessels May Embark armed security
teams uh but certainly it isn't a one
size fit or plan for the waters or the
region what's going to be the impact of
on trading costs if ships are unable to
use this
route So currently we are not seeing a
complete shutdown by any means of the
Red Sea route the the implications
currently are very much the at the kind
of individual operator level what is
important to highlight is the concern
for the sea farers themselves who are
actually transporting the goods who are
who are sailing the vessels along this
route and that has been a concern
highlighted by several of the operators
who have elected to pause their
shipments uh in the current
circumstances so we've seen statements
from various liners who've said that
they would like they they plan to pause
uh and take stock of the situation in
the coming days but what we're also
seeing is one of the major concerns is
around insurance premium so this is
something which will push costs up and
these will be passed along the chain as
you mentioned in your piece earlier the
costs have gone up almost 300% in some
cases but across the board War risk
premiums will increase cost for
operators and we'll also see increased
cost and also delays where vessels rroo
so rather than taking the Red Sea Su
Canal transit route you can instead the
alternative is to sail around the coast
of Africa uh and that would be the
alternative for a lot for any Asia
Europe trade that will add days uh days
to any Transit will require additional
Port Cs and it will require additional
Fuel and additional cost and all of
these will add into the cost of any
shipments And Trades now we know that
the US defense secretary is in the
process of trying to uh hold discussions
about an expanded Naval Force for
protection of shipping what difference
is that likely to make to to shippers
that are go using this
route So currently the details regarding
the uh possible broading of the naval
presence in the region are unclear and
so we wouldn't be able to State exactly
what the difference will be by any
expansion or broadening of Naval Assets
in the region but what we can say is
that the naval forces have demonstrated
a capacity to assist to render
assistance and to help vessels who are
using this route and that will be Contin
that will continue and any broadening of
the number of Assets in the region and
the number of monitoring surveillance
for example would all assist vessels
continuing to use the Sue as red sea
route Victoria mitro from control risks
we appreciate it thank you very much
indeed thank you